anger over potential rule breaking is
compounded by the fact that the prime
minister confirmed england will move to
plan b restrictions amid warnings over
the rapid spread of the omicron variant
and this afternoon we've heard that the
number of omicron cases in the uk has
nearly doubled in one day after a
further 249 cases were confirmed
bringing the total to 817.
the health secretary sanjit javid has
said that implementing restrictions now
will mean we could avoid the need for
further measures in the future
but sage documents suggest that plan b
is unlikely to be enough even if the
disease is milder with omicron the spy-m
modelling group warned if omicron in the
uk combines increased transmissibility
and immune escape irrespective of
severity it is highly likely that very
stringent measures would be required to
control growth and keep r below one
let's take a look now at the uk's daily
covered data which has just been
published there have been 50
867
new cases of covid 19 recorded in the
last 24 hours down slightly on
yesterday's figure
another 148 deaths have been reported
within 28 days of a positive test and
that brings the total number of deaths
in the uk to 146 thousand one hundred
and thirty five
to the vaccine rollout and twenty one
thousand seven hundred people received
their first dose of a vaccine while 29
and 437 people received their second
dose that means the total number of
people to have received their second
dose is over 46.6
million
and 414
and
645 booster and third jabs were given in
the latest 24-hour period taking the
total number of those doses to more than
21.7 million
so could further restrictions be needed
well our science correspondent thomas
moore has been assessing the impact of
the new plan b rules
you're certainly not going to control uh
this variant with the
measures that we have in place now even
the ones that we have uh certainly
aren't being applied as rig as
rigorously as they could be the covid
pass for example only applies to
large gatherings it doesn't mean you can
go to a restaurant and assume that there
will be nobody
in that restaurant who doesn't have
omicron and certainly i'm listening to
scientists who are telling me that
they certainly wouldn't feel comfortable
in in those settings so the kobe pass
would need to be used much more widely
in
groups of which are much smaller than at
present
you would also need to
enforce
social distancing they're very concerned
that this virus is more
airborne than than previous variants and
that would mean that masks social
distancing reduced density in in bars
and restaurants all those measures uh
would need to come back to to make a
difference as well as ventilation and in
some older buildings that's just not
possible so there are big doubts that
whether the the current controls are
going to make a significant difference
and that is the big worry that that this
is
spreading so fast that something called
the tyranny of exponential rise so you
can have a thousand cases today
and in two weeks time this thing is
spreading so fast uh you would have
sixty four thousand uh it is that bad
and you would expect a big rise in in
hospital admissions too
even if it is causing milder disease in
the majority there would still be some
who are still exposed to very serious
risk of of
hospitalization and that is why they are
so worried that this could lead to a big
problem in hospitals and that's not very
far away i mean you're looking at a
thousand admissions by the end of this
year uh without interventions and as i
say there are doubts whether these
interventions are going to make that
much difference to to what what is going
to happen in the near future